every breath of air that we take there's
about a million particles of dust and if
you can imagine you're trying to build
lasers to the size that they're a
hundred times smaller than the width of
a single human hair where there's all
these giant things floating around its
approximately like trying to do
chemistry in a chemistry lab when you
got blimps floating around in the room
and so if one of these blimps lands on
your chemistry experiment your experiment
is ruined and we see the same sort of
things with our lasers if we have a
particle of dust that lands in the wrong
place it will ruin our laser or whatever
else you're trying to make so at UC San
Diego we have a giant clean room
facility and they've got impressive
filters that are just filtering and
filtering out all this dust as best they
can and so they've got it down from
a million particles of dust in every
breath of air to something like ten to a
hundred particles but to keep the dust
that low they have to wear these full
body suits and that's not so much to
protect us from the things in the clean
room its to protect the cleanroom from
us so that we keep our personal dust
contained and keep it out of the clean
room
what did you think of the video? let us
know in the comments below and make sure
to subscribe to Fig. 1!